but it's really just a privilege to
introduce David may you on this occasion
and in one sense he's obviously a person
who needs no introduction to any of us
in that we've all been learning from his
work assigning his work for many years
but I guess what to me what's what's
striking in as I look back and think
about David's career spanning now over
almost 50 years and still going quite
strong is how he's really transformed
our understanding not just of Congress
but of many core features of the
American political system this is a
career that really starts with his first
book party loyalty among congressmen and
to his most recent partisan balance why
political parties don't kill the u.s.
constitutional system david has taught
us so much about the role parties play
in our political system both in
representing the public and at times
making policy and at times failing to
make policy and teaching us about that
he set scholarly agendas in several
subfield mo Fiorina referred to the work
on divided government we're basically
launching a whole cottage industry of
studies of the impact of divided
government on legislative productivity
in gridlock his book electoral
realignments a critique of an American
genre really single-handedly moved
scholars away from one line of inquiry
and hopefully into more fruitful ways of
thinking about American electoral
history now David may use most famous as
we've talked about a lot in the in the
first panel firs his book the electoral
connection Congress the electoral
connection which as we talked about
really revolutionized the way we study
Congress but to me I guess my
appreciation for that book in the the
true testament to David's kind of
intellectual role in the field is to
juxtapose that book in some ways with a
book he wrote almost 30 years later
called America's Congress actions in the
public sphere now the electoral
connection if we've taught as we've
talked about is an exercise in useful
simplification it takes a very simple
idea simple premise and through
clear-headed reasoning shows us how far
that premise can
make us to understand politics America's
Congress is a much different book at
least on the surface rather than
simplifying and abstracting it focuses
on specific events and individuals and
is really focused on the question of
when we think about what is it that
members of Congress do that's
significant what can we learn about the
nature of the political system we
inhabit in the role of Congress in
maintaining that system and so and so
it's coming at it from a very different
perspective in one of the key insights
there is that one of the things members
of Congress do is not just respond to
voters preferences but they're actually
actors in a public sphere helping to
shape public opinion shape public debate
now that's one of the most important
things members of Congress do now I
think what's striking is that while
these that while these two books come at
Congress from two very different angles
they share that common mayhew Ian
analytic sharpness that that's kind of
bite where you just see these insights
that leap out of this initial move he
makes a simple move at the start this
simplifying assumption in Congress the
electoral connection this idea of
thinking about what is it that members
do that's significant in this later book
and then uses that insight to then
generate a whole series of new ways of
thinking about how Congress works and so
I think to me coming from at the
institution from these two seemingly
opposite lenses you see this same common
kind of intellectual structure now I was
fortunate to have studied at Yale with
David may you and I think the I was here
for six years from 1991 297 I can report
we did have graduate seminars in
American politics while I was here as my
first class was Ashley the field seminar
with David may you and one of the things
that stood out to me was coming from a
small liberal arts college where I was
kind of used to just sort of spouting
off with great you know what I thought
was great political wisdom about how
American politics works I would hand in
these short essays and like and David
would come back at me with you know
where's the evidence for this claim you
know
exactly what's the logic behind this
argument I just wasn't in and quickly he
kind of disciplined me to think about
how you know just the importance in it
that we want to be theoretical we want
to make big claims but we also need to
really know the stuff of politics we
need to have empirical basis for all of
our claims and so I got that early on
and then continued throughout my time at
Yale I think the thing that stuck out to
me most is long lunches at Clark's
restaurant with David working on as I
was in the process of taking my vague
idea for a dissertation and trying to
turn it into something practical and do
infeasible and so we would spend these
at lunches and there'd be two hours
three hour lunches where we would go
over the prospectus the latest
perspectives draft or chapter draft and
David would give just painstakingly
detailed comments and we'd work through
the various problems issues discuss
difficult cases alternative explanations
and you know I can say the food at
clarks it's not something that all that
memorable but the mentoring experience I
got there is something that's stuck with
me to this day and just taught me how to
be an advisor to graduate students and
so it's still now I when I think about
my own role as an advisor to students I
think to myself well you know is this
the kind of level of feedback engagement
and closer to just care that that that
David showed to me and really made a
tremendous difference in my development
so I would say both from his research
and from his work as a mentor I really
learned about what it means to be be a
be a scholar and to contribute to not
just your own research but to that of
future generations of scholars and so
with that welcome David me
I can see this is so I can see yes I'm
gonna have more to say later I'll be
back but right now I've got a particular
assignment given to me by Ellen Gerber
particular assignment and I'm not
supposed to talk he told me anyway more
than 15 minutes it's now being elongated
into 20 but here we are this was the
assignment and from Allen this book of
which we have about which had the panel
this one in the electrical connection
book which was now 40 years ago as was
as written actually 40 years ago
published 39 years ago as doug said 30
years ago written where did it come from
where did the book come from what is the
genesis one of the origins out of this
get on the boards in such this butcher
now which is this is a kind of personal
archaeology here this is going back a
long time it's longer in time than
almost anybody else possibly anybody
else for that matter and the audience
can go and maybe the oldest inhabitant
of the room come to think of it not by
much in some instances but still I may
have the record there it is now here is
the here is I want to give you some
ingredients again this is marquis ology
but it says something about the times
about the context and about the as the
Yale department as well as a profession
as well as the country it's just I'm
back in the 1970s is so I here are some
where did the book come from where did
the book come from a local connection
okay here are some ingredients I've got
I guess five ingredients and then some
thoughts to the reefs together the end
of a discussion first of all first of
all I'd been reading a lot especially
the only thing I know how to do which is
to read you know I don't know how to do
numbers or game theory or interviews
interviews with people strike me as
being a horrible thing to have to do
these structured or otherwise I wouldn't
know how to do it I can hardly use the
telephone but I know how to read I know
how to read I really know how to read
I've always known how to read so it's a
background a very important background
it's kind of a literature or literary
background the writing of this book in
the mid seventies was and I'd read a lot
I've been reading alive for a long time
I read a lot as an undergrad at the
graduate school my advisor a graduate
schools vo key I'd virtually memorized
everything that vo key had written and
some of the other kind of North kind of
analytic style moves that you find
probably in my advisor key would be
evident what I was doing later round it
was there also i read the Congressional
Record I noticed that one of the one of
the papers i think it's the etsy i read
all the great papers will talk about
them later at least I will one of the
lipid the the the Lipinski Clinton
Katznelson paper i think they counseled
us to read the congressional record
isn't that true back there in the 1930s
and 40s you really should do that you
know just look and see get a sense of
the context the content look in and see
what's going on so you see how people
who are voting get the flavor there's a
lot of the flavor actually of the
Congressional Record in fact some
quotations in my electoral connection
book I used to get it every day the
Congressional Record hard copy it was it
turns out that I think at that time
every congressman congressman they were
virtually all men bath then had 25 free
subscriptions to the congressional
record in the district and I got one at
an early time and for maybe 12 years I
got the damn thing every day I'd I
really would look at it I really look at
Congressional Record i probably spent an
hour every day with a congressional
record going through it it cost be
stupid the reddit read agreed everywhere
but there it was and this is before
congressional quarterly amounted to much
it was on the boards but it was thing it
was very thin it wasn't a national
journal I was no way near the Washington
Post and there was so this is a major
source there there was it was it you had
to do it yeah that's one thing you had
to do after the secondary work by
journalists on the Congress is not all
that great compared with today also what
I did is a still at a point number one
about reading after I got out of
graduate school which was in 63 the fall
of 63 I discovered that I didn't know
much about political science I taken
some nice courses that i love my courses
i love the setting i love what i learned
but i knew virtually nothing about
political science so what I did was to
go back in all the journals that had
articles about American politics
anything to do with American politics or
not that many
then it did this that there were some
all the way back to calendar 1950 that
is I systematically went through all the
journals from 1950 through whatever it
was i got in 1963-64 and i continue this
after that for years reading and
clocking all these pieces about American
politics I still have the cards they
know there's a stack of cards that thick
index cards this is also before
computers just tanking up tanking up
whatever there was we're in the way of
knowledge accumulated stuff about
American politics particularly about
Congress but also elections and other
stuff state politics at that point state
politics which is a bigger deal and
studying American politics then than it
is now for political scientist I did all
eyes are reading so there's a reading
base going into the 1970s which was as I
say that's what I chiefly know how to do
secondly secondly I had time on Capitol
Hill and this is a great big piece of
fortune for me in the mid-60s the APS a
congressional fellowship a great big
piece of good fortune and I really do
recommend that council it and we've
talked about this a name people try to
get into the trench you really go down
there and do it I've talked to Keith
Grable about this i think federal told
me you just got to go down there and do
that whereas keith did he tell you that
yelled you spend time about dolls office
which is very valuable isn't that
correct it's just very important to get
oriented to get a sense of the place or
what kind of stuff goes on in the place
i did that i went down in 67 68 my
congressional fellowship they worked in
our house office and i worked in the
senate office for a while i also worked
in the office of the Democratic study
group for a few weeks down there
actually this is a preface asst what
gary jacobs edit i were later fussing
with in the early 70s their campaign
finance data that I systematize for them
that caffeinate campaign aides campaign
finance contribution records back in 67
68 did that but very valuable on the
hill was watching how the members
operated as SS congressional fellow I
had access to the offices i could sit
right in the offices of the folks the
house member of the Senate member and
see what they did during the day and
there was and i think a lot of my
electrical connection book comes out of
perception or my actually my perception
of my reading of what they were up to as
I watched them operate as people came
through the office or watch though
upright in the floor I went back to the
district's I went back to New Jersey i
went to Montana I could see that people
dealing with their constituents back
there in the other settings I could see
that this is very valuable I remember
they was my house member from New Jersey
I think that I without thinking about it
very deeply I coated what he was up to
probably and what are what I later but
on paper as the as the set of categories
of petition position taking and credit
claiming and advertised think I'd see
that not exactly in those terms but I
could watch my boss and I could see
people would come through the office and
with with four people in trend it would
be goodies distributive politics for the
unions who would be solicitude
accommodation will do it you on it so
far as is possible for the Princeton
folks it was positions the Princeton
folks love positions and my boss a
double this a double this campaign
finance contributions to the princeton
area by coming out against the Vietnam
War and you know what he was doing as he
as he came out with his position against
the Vietnam War they love positions in
Princeton it was a there was a kind of
differentiation of effort and you could
see the man putting on different kinds
of you could actually see different
kinds of skulk whatever cap says he was
operating with different kinds of
constituents as they did come through
and also see him operating out there Lee
in Trenton going and visiting the gin
bills and such which I did a little bit
with him it's fascinating so just
fascinating stuff that's just watching I
didn't have any project in mind or just
at that point any of this but this
project in mind I'm just watching to see
if they were up to all right that's two
ingredients a third ingredient of the of
the book which has been talked about in
a general sense this morning by by some
of summits of the panelists is after all
the political setting of the 19 late
1960s and
and in 1970s now it's very clear that
some things were happening that as the
incumbency advantage was rising with
surging at least we seem it seemed to be
the case and actually it's now been
clocked by him bye bye Steve and Jim
that this is going on in a lot of
electoral realms after all back in the
50s we know though now there's better
evidence on these things but we could
see it's especially involving US House
members and then I in the in the night
in the night and then I in the 1970s we
can see that we could also see thee well
that's need to be that seemed to denote
a kind of individuation of politics that
hadn't been quite there before we could
see the increase in the programs that
we're generating casework as more wrote
about we could see the the the apex of
cross party voting on Capitol Hill that
isn't that is to say not party V party
but rather something else in the
politics often in the 1960s and 70s in
all of American history is a trough as
we know in party voting and the one
probably peeking in it so far as a
trough can be peeking in the 1970s
something like that there it was these
things were happening and that was a
setting and some of us were resonating
to the same setting doing that and I was
talked about this barbaric who was
writing about incumbency advantage in
1971 before I got on to that wagon you
know that but it wasn't out there
independently we were responding to the
same environment and they had changes in
that political environment i was struck
this morning listening to Gary I didn't
quite thought about this before if I
watched watching it watching his charts
there looking at his charts that as of
1973 when I wrote that book I'd been
watching politics for a quarter of a
century which tells me something about
my vintage I mean it goes all the way
back and I could see or one of the yes
one of the one of the one of the
properties of the evolution that went
along with that vintage that I could see
the change over a quarter of a century
producing this politics are emanating in
this palette which is not an end point
but there it was emanating in this
politics of the 1970s which did entail
cross-party voting and it
situation and encompass the advantage
shoot up all the way back I mean I've
been watching I've been I mean back and
back and I have I have I have I memories
all the way back to nineteen forty eight
nineteen fifty and actually in nineteen
forty eight nineteen fifty the 50s he
might dim now memories of that will
resonate to Gary's charts which was that
the cleavage in the country back in
those days was indeed quite partisan by
the by comparison with the with the
politics is voting congressional voting
and such in the 1960s and 70s I could
see that back at my own room my
elementary school in 1948 Democrats his
first Republicans for example it was
virtually religious census of
Protestants versus Catholics really I
think just about perfect a census of
Catholic in my village Catholics versus
Protestants and I was a Protestant we
got whomped in my village we duly people
got watch by the traumen people i think
was 21 26 the 11 13 school i couldn't
understand that until some years later I
realized it was the emanation of a other
interesting of a religious census i
still have clippings in the file from
1950 elections all the way back there so
the point i'm making care about this is
that i was sensitized by Gary stretch to
the point that as of 1973 I'd been
seeing the evolution toward of changes
toward what we were seeing in the early
1970s for quite a long time I mean I was
seeing yes and some time in some places
the book does comment about how things
are changing in this direction it a date
they they seem to have been there it is
that's the political setting of the time
the fourth ingredient is this one of the
writing of this book it has to do with
the the Yale intellectual environment of
of the early 1970s I got here in in 1968
and some folks have talked about this
gary was here then a little later than
that little later doug arnold was here
chris akin was here was here then the
idea was a hothouse department at that
time after all in the in the in the
profession and it was the environment
was here was the environment as i think
it impinged on me
around 1970s oh I do it was there was
sharp analytics ism was in the air that
is that's that was what was valued their
sharp analytics of some kind or another
as opposed to what I supposed to gassing
on supposed to doing whatever you know
sharp analytics something like that
something like that we saw it and that's
unkind because they're right there it is
only kind because some of my own writing
doesn't after all doesn't have champagne
all the text but it mounts rather the
gassing on so i don't want to i want to
be a little careful here but it was it
was the the Bob doll was here after all
and at lindblom Bob lane they were at
the at the at the the oldest the most
senior members of the senior faculty at
that time Joel open bar was here and
while insincere David after was coming
in at the at the junior Lawrence not
junior but it's yes Junior libero
somewhat younger level after all there
was Jerry Kramer had come aboard and he
was a smart fearsome figure was Jerry
Kramer stern that is the intellectual
Eastern was Jerry there was a Dougray
who was was a walking a walking
expositor of analytics as was Dougray
around 1970s I was joking to remember
looming in the background was martin
shubik out there of another fearsome
figure was martin shubik whom I did not
know but some summer since told i think
that i think dr. Arnold says in his
paper that he did worries his true did
work with the Martin did you go see
Martin where's Doug where's yeah yeah
yes should be Ken Kramer right so there
was this was this is the environment
that was the environment I was operating
it or trying to operate in at that time
and another figure or another writer it
was not at Yale but what's very
important in the intellectual context
the swing of the time was it's also been
mentioned by Doug arnoldus wanting
Anthony downs now he wasn't here he was
at Brookings or something I don't know
where he was but his preference is what
does the name of it he could advocacy
you there it is was was very very very
much out there and it
was much favored in the Yale department
that book it was propagated promulgated
used just out there I had lindblom was a
big fan of downs his book for example it
was in the air of the downs his book and
now it's very important to me as a
theoretical enterprise that I remember a
particular point actually in the writing
of the electrical connection at the
downs book it does erupt in a particular
way I was teaching a graduate seminar 11
year in the early 70s and I was I think
i was using downs his book i must have
been doing that and going into class it
occurred to me go maybe I could do
something useful by by by by
generalizing or rather complicating
complicating what downs was doing in his
basic thinking what was that parties
after all a point Saracen about points
are points or said of e-edit ease that
could be with each other for elections
but suppose you suppose you take that
premise to the Congressional level so
you're not dealing with just one off it
11 presidential candidate or one party
or something but rather with an assembly
or two Assemblies of 535 people how does
the how does the dancing premise wander
into the environment of 102 435 and
that's what induced me to make the
distinction I think it did anyway having
watched my boss in action on Capitol
Hill be telling position taking and
credit claiming that is that these are
not these are not emphasis that arise so
easily or quickly to the head as well
thinks about presidents or about parties
running things whereas with 535
individual people why they leap to the
head more easily so that was there that
was there that was there yes that's the
num for the Yale intellectual
environment of that time a fifth
ingredient was this one the electrical
connection book is a it's a theoretical
essay that's what it is that's
theoretical essay and somebody said to
me once did you write that over a
weekend there's a Loudred no I didn't
write it over a weekend but it is it is
there's out
it is rather short and rather simple
after all in some ways after all the
structure simple and it's not and it's
not a quantitative enterprise except for
a few fugitive charts it's really quite
as a thought enterprise and how is one
to do that I mean what was the what was
the basis in political science or
tradition or the acceptance rate for
writing a theoretical essays me that is
not where the things were going or where
they seem to have been for that matter
writing theoretical essays whatever
exactly a theoretical essay is but but I
did that and I it's a it's it's a form
of presentation that I decided to do
double ven soo in 790 73 is so there and
I think there are a couple of precedents
for that they were in my in my
background a couple of models for me I
was trying to figure out her figure into
doing that one was Lee hearts as I
studied at Harvard with Louie hearts
quite a bit low E you know Loihi of the
liberal tradition in America at three
courses with Louie hearts that was the
first place mommy is a course taking
experience at at Harvard it is quite
outside my domain after all what we is
doing he's doing your peon political
thought he's doing after mostly mostly
chiefly bad plus a liberal tradition in
America but what the liberal tradition
in America was a book which was very in
the front of my head in the 60s and 70s
and it's a theoretical SA node what he
does is to take a pretty simple idea and
traffic through and take it through a
lot of terrain make it visit a lot of
terrain over American history that is he
inserts puts through a particular idea
through a lot of material that's what
then on the the more proximate model i
would say for getting into the
theoretical as i did with bob dole's
work bob dole's work in particular his
work
a preface to democratic theory a preface
to democratic theory which was written
when I guess in the 1960s maybe even the
1950s I don't know well it's still a
very important book after all then it is
exactly a theoretical essay that as Bob
tells breakfast is not long doesn't have
numbers in it it's a thought piece which
covers a fair amount of terrain and
plays through it a premise about
democracy which makes some wrinkles
along itself as it goes through the book
and it's fairly short you could have
written it in a weekend maybe I'm sure
he didn't so that was a so that was it
was a kind of a model I think I my name
sure I thought it out as being a kind of
a model but I don't think probably that
the that's that the awareness of the the
hearts work and the particular doll work
the preference work were in my arsal or
not exactly in my head as I went into
the writing the electoral connection a
nineteen nineteen seventy-three all
right those are the five ingredients
then of it of getting into that it's my
assignment from Alan and so it's a the
book came together in 1973 I wrote it
and I did but some preparatory couple of
essays that I screed it out a couple of
a couple of years earlier which chris
naked reminded me of the other day
virtually forgotten about them but I
wrote the book in the summer of 73 it
took about 13 weeks with the right which
is more than a weekend about 13 weeks I
had it all lined up I had the I had a
stack of cards to write from that is
there ever the quotes and references as
such that i had had stacked up during
the preceding academic year I've never
succeeded in writing and teaching at the
same time I just can't though it's like
Jerry Ford I don't know how to do those
two things at once I couldn't do that so
I did needed the space the time the
slack the summer actually to do the
writing you know flat out without
without interruptions in it which I and
that's what i did in december 73
actually that was a summer of sam evans
hearings you know is there was one of
the two big Watergate summers that's the
one in which Sam Ervin and his folks
took the skin off from Nixon and his
folks in that summer so what I would
I couldn't watch them during the day
because I had to write so fortunately
one of the channels they would take them
and then running at night so I'd write
during the way right during the day and
watch Sam Beavan at night to figure out
to find out about what a date what had
going on in that setting 30 today it was
a lot of fun and the writing went rather
smoothly I there was only one glitch as
I remember it I thought the whole thing
out pretty well there was one glitch it
was having a thing about how to define
credit claiming and I wrestled with that
for a while and I would never satisfy
what I got but then there's i adopted I
think I consciously did this above that
Bob del sometimes made it is writing
which is to say that well I can't solve
everything here so let's just do the
best I can I get beyond it you know get
to the next paragraph in the next page
he commonly did that that's what i did
with credit claiming it's got some holes
in it I know it's custom holes in it
it's got unclear boundaries but I had to
stop I had to go on to the next page so
I did that but generally speaking the
whole went the whole thing went pretty
smoothly and the let me show you
something recently in those days we
wrote in handwriting I mean for
youngsters that's nearly inconceivable
this is before certainly before
computers it's also before I would I
think it's before electric electric
typewriters at least there was it was in
those days what you would commonly do if
you're writing something long is to put
it in handwriting and then send it to a
typist so that's what i did i put it in
handwriting and i fished it out I've got
it here in handwriting now this is
actually this is a photocopy of the
handwriting I think the typist never
gave back the copy you know but being a
bit operating on an insurance principle
which I very commonly do I made a
photocopy of the whole thing for I sent
it to the typist you really do want to
do that me there are these stories about
dissertations being lost in a trunk in
the car stolen you know that's very
common so this was the result of doing
the photocopy taken putting in the
closet I just took it took it out a few
a few months ago and take a look at it
there
and that was it just writing it and
getting it over to thee and I had to
write something else has got to lose my
job very quickly so the summer of
nineteen seventy-three was very critical
to that Joe we remember that I had to
get that stuff on paper no and even
there there was that was it and then I
wrote the book crafting this what
theoretical enterprise and then I
stopped I never did anything more in
that front there was I just stopped I'd
had said everything to say about it that
I wanted to say and that was the end of
it said that's the end of this
questions for Megan yes ma you were
mentioning models for the now that's an
interesting point and I think maybe
you're right about that it's quite maybe
especially Sammy sovereign people that
might have been also in my yes it might
have been there also that's another very
distinguished after all theoretical
essay I think maybe you're right so
let's mile magnified by fifty percent my
claim and add on Elmer I think that's
probably right but what else can you
think of that would be of that it's not
that common was it wasn't that common
was it no excuse me a probably a bit
later I mean most people didn't write
that sort of a thing I made wares exit
voice I don't remember when it was icy
but I wasn't aware of it I don't think I
was aware of it no was outside Polly
sites officially so the least I wasn't
reading it there what but most people in
do that my advisor vo didn't write key
didn't write write the affetto didn't
write theoretical yes I don't think so
anyway yes well I wouldn't know I would
I don't say seismic that's more
elaborate it's more it's got more in it
it's got more smaller production
congressman and committees it's really
got a lot of I also interview material I
wouldn't put it in the same I wouldn't
put it in the same bucket I don't think
I don't think I would anyway don't think
so but you're right about I think Josh
Snyder that's quite all I know that I
certainly know his work yeah so do be
three books excuse me no David you end
your story with the with the completion
of the work and I'm not rested in and
you never came back to it I mean it's
actually interesting i'm sure you were
asked many times to do a second or third
or fourth edition you know well you
didn't do the second so you don't get to
do the third or fourth so I'm curious
about what the
what the immediate reception was what
the immediate reception was to the book
I don't want like we're aware in the in
the end the American policies academic
world i think was picked up pretty quick
but in two or three years i think it was
yes picked up pretty quick in the public
affairs world not so much it was
interviewed it was reviewed by what
Walter Shapiro and they in the
Washington Monthly had a little bit of a
public face though not as much as
obviously much of some some works too
but yes it got picked up pretty fast but
but then I stopped I think one reason I
stopped well I stopped chiefly because I
didn't have anything more to say on this
point I mean there it was but then the
going sporting spooning forth a few
years the rational choice analysis I
really didn't know how to do I mean I do
how to do simple premises but I'd had no
training and so therefore obviously when
I capable of carrying forth the whole
business and they and the elaborate
fashion that rational choice a training
would have would have supplied would
have supplied no was i interested in
doing that really i mean i was
interested in moving on finding some
other kind of thing to do and generally
speaking what i have done is to move on
to do something somewhat different you
know
guys are congressmen or what ah good
lord I don't know what I think about
that it's good well it's kind of I don't
I really don't know it's uh I don't know
if I like it it's a it might be better
if they're doing something else but what
can I tell you what could I tell you
yeah yeah oh well I really died in
leaving aside use additions or something
I mean it is a market in the u.s. you
know marked up use it it's something
like a hundred thousand maybe something
like that but I really don't know I lost
track a long time ago and I never I
never got much in the way of royalties
pardon i think so i think it helped them
a bit dro it up okay sure enough they
see that's because I'm become hard of
hearing maybe that's the end of it maybe
we went a round table people want round
table
I just wonder if you'd say you said a
word about Louis hearts as a teacher if
you'd say a bit about V okie the they
were very different Louis as teacher
Louis hearts was charismatic in seminars
as well as in lectures really was just
really just followings Pied Piper cut a
guy was Louie hearts and for good reason
very good reason just a very good reason
vo was very different vo was soft-spoken
the low spoken the recessive did really
care it didn't was not a star
undergraduate teacher and didn't try to
be a star at the Graduate see she ready
to work with like undergraduate course
in seminars here and kind of V okie I
had a couple of his seminars by the
books seminars on subjects I'd had one
parties when I parties without
legislative behavior I think he was
terrific but he's just a different
different different kind of presentation
from from Lou even very right yeah
always very very good also vo was very
very very helpful helpful to me I mean
respectful we read my work when I put in
front of my remember I gave my first
three chapters of my dissertation and I
had a chart in the axis or upside down
you know they asked with the why and why
with the Agra and in no you can't do
that blah blah blah he was loud he
vented and corrected and by bursary
chapters and veered me toward the doing
the whole business better and then he
got sick and never recovered the vo you
know at 63 he did